first step
settling grounding
drill
leave that foot in that 45
this foot
turn into a nutmeg
let your
body drop okay
okay try
this time
i'll walk into
that stance so
i shift my weight shift my weight walk
into the stance
shift
go back other ways from the back
step into it
okay
oh my hand is gonna go out my hand's
gonna go with the foot so my hand goes
with the foot and i'm gonna drop my
elbow
hand goes with the foot
okay try it
i'll try tie the
reverse punch to the other hand
elbow
boom
reverse punch
uh
okay
so that
down
tied with the foot
tied with the moving foot and a reverse
punch
tied with the settling okay this elbow
is just tied with the 7th
well i have circles
circles
a not not straight not disconnected
movement so
i'm going to go
straight
okay let's try it again okay so we'll
combine a couple drills
he's gonna have some conditioning
getting used to things okay
i'm not hitting him with rotational
torque i'm not doing that okay
uh i i'll hit him with the settling so
the settling comes around and i'm going
to home settle do you understand
try to try to do don't sit here and go
got it so it's a settling that hit and
this isn't how you punch people this
isn't how i fight this is just
i'm going to add his resistance
to my resistance meaning his
gravitational pull to my gravitational
pull
so that's what i
coach you project through him
not rotational torque okay
so i just drop
okay try okay
so
you're not punching the circle you're
not doing like heavy back work okay
you're doing
uh
you're doing the internal aspects at a
ballistic
pace
okay so if she pushes on me like she's
pushing on me
that is a fixating case okay so now
we're doing it ballistically okay
so she's the little target for me for
your leg square i'm gonna punch you but
it's not a punch
okay and i'll slow it down so you can
see what happens
same project
same projection
same
projection do you see that oh
we're just
doing it
a little sean
i have to achieve the same thing without
turning it into an external function
so some of the things you'll notice is
my hand can be quite open
are you seeing
that i don't need that
perfect fit to be quiet
okay you see that okay
so it's not
there's a there's a co-q projection in
the middle of it but it's ballistic got
it okay so you have to try to do the
drills
you're doing the drill so whatever your
your drill is like coming around and
i'll
not do the drill do you see but i'm just
doing it ballistically now
same exact
okay try to
say
i could i could do it small
small
you can do it big
you can't see how loose the fist
okay
a projection
okay so she's doing that drill
right
you
[Music]
so
so uh again this is a it's a drill it's
a development it's meant to train you
you see it's not it's not a fighting
thing okay
if you go into the ego duel
right and we're over here and we're
doing this kind of stuff
uh i'd use the same skills but not the
same tactics okay
so for example right here he's gonna
come in and this leg is what i'm going
to hit okay so look how you have all
your weight on that leg okay
so on that leg i'll hit it
you know with the weapon that doesn't
bring me into range
i see that
and that's going to be my leg
okay
so don't i'm going through it hard okay
but i'm not going to go boom
you're going to feel the same
same exact uh
projection through you and are you right
okay so now now you just have to imagine
boom at that speed on the same
mechanic the same engine okay but this
is a drill
not a tactic okay
and i can use this drill
to
understand how
uh you can get
in
the beginning part of your kihon wasn't
okay so let me
take the run around me person okay
so i'm gonna be
the one punch
okay
so are you gonna punch you're gonna do
your technique
okay you're ready you're gonna do the
last row
you're gonna do something
that's not it
okay you're gonna do something so she
moved out of the way that's what you
noted firstly she moved out of the way
externally
but i am perfectly
imbalanced do you see that
so
i would i still have the initiative
because she responded to me do you
understand now if she's blocking right
then i have the internal skills i i
actually have more than the initiative
okay do you get that
uh but let's say i didn't have internal
skills but see i just catch you on the
second one
do you understand okay so
what's happening is when when i try to
do things external
as you noted you're too far away
too far away but more importantly they
don't go into kazushi
if they if she does the technique move
far away like you were with your block
and then she'll do something
you see and then the guy goes like that
right the problem is that i was waiting
there for forever
do you see that
so as opposed to she's doing her strikes
right
i want her to go off balance so
sometimes she's here and i take it off
balance
sometimes it's on the stick
can you see on the stick sometimes i
take a blow because it's not going to do
anything do you understand there's not
enough penetration
but right away in the middle of her
thing
off balance
so in order to do that i can't do this
can you see
and in order to not do that
i have to have
the internals it allows me to do that
allows me to she goes and boom i can do
you see how energy went back and did you
feel that energy went back into her and
so she goes
boom and this is where i can come in
if i wanted just to attack but here i
could use it also to yield
you see
or just to barely get out of the way
barely out of the way
but balance goes right away do you
understand
she goes again different
you're just waiting here like that and
she's going to do another one and
like no it's not going to
okay so in the drill what i want you to
do
is she's trying to do the drill and i'm
doing the drill back to her
stick
okay try to not
get afraid
and move way out of the way
you got it try to be
i know that she could punch
and it goes right back into her okay and
punches
and then
what i mean is your panic of not wanting
to get touched by her lightsaber fist
you see it's making you
go into the eager tripartite fear cycle
and that'll kick you out of the internal
applications so
every once in a while i just
let her boom hit and then go
but you can see that it keeps projecting
sometimes no
sometimes not at all
see and if i touch your hands the same
way that i stuck there when i yield i
touch your hand pull your hand back
do you see same kind of adhesion
got it here don't go to the external and
go i got out of the way
doing this
or you're doing this she's going to pull
her hand back
do you understand you're going to find
your adhesion
pull your hand back
do you see
okay
try
i'll be there okay okay she'll do her
thing
i'll be back okay
reach for those reach
so
here if she did the first yield where
you got a lot of distance and external
yield do you remember yeah there we go
full and i have my balance do you see
and now we're here do the other one
i still have my balance
you see that
so uh go ahead
where does the kazushi come from
that's the question okay
so when she comes in it comes from
non-contestation
non-contestation okay but not external
internal non-contest station so there i
didn't even move when you saw that it
bounced off the ground and came back
into the shoulder okay
maybe i let her touch me but she stuck
to me you see she stuck to me
i can't go here
stop you
and then
try to project there has to be a yield
you have to create a yin space okay has
to be a yin space a in space
but the in space should be internal
internal
external
then a push
internal oh
you see internal heel space okay
all right try it
okay so now as you do your heels
uh take them into one of the kazushi
patterns so you got a two front inwards
and then two rear outwards okay so you
can't just go here
you go you gotta take him into the
kadushi pattern
this is
i'm breaking down the powders that you
see
right
alright
i break it
hmm
okay